la société le seul moment vous devez pas
avoir de masques seat a d'abord vous
devez manger vous le faites un table
mais vous ne pouvez pas être en train de
manger circuler avec son humeur ce qui
est interdit c'est la rentrée et pas
facile pour tout le monde de se faire
aux nouvelles règles au réfectoire
on s'assoit en quinconce et on porte son
masque à chaque déplacement même pour
prendre un verre d'eau le court aux
navires us à bousculer les habitudes des
internautes
et foin des réflexes d'enlever le masque
pasquini dérange ou quoi que ce soit
c'est un peu fatigant mais on s'y
habitue
oui c'est contraignant tant pour eux que
pour nous ce serait quand même dommage
que sur leurs lieux de vie dans leur
famille il n'est pas attraper la maladie
et que ce soit au sein de
l'établissement qui doit être sécurisé
qu'ils viennent attrapé la maladie alors
les 170 interne gardent leurs distances
même dans les dortoirs ici la chambre
ils ont placé les meubles de manière à
ce que ce qui est je pense que grosso
merdo 1 m entre les lits je veux dire il
y à il ya un espacement d'un mètre entre
les tables à l'heure de l'étude
chacun reste à son bureau dans les
salles de bains on se lave les dents
uniquement entre collègues de chambre
c'est forcément contraignant on ne voit
pas bien qu ce qu'on pourrait faire
d'autre de mieux à priori pour l'instant
en tout cas si on veut accueillir tous
les élèves qui nous ont fait la demande
de l'internât en cas de suspicion de
qu'ovide l'élève est isolé et testé mais
la direction de l'établissement là sur
la fermeture complète de l'internât
n'est pas au programme
finie l'époque des soirées télé et des
rencontres entre chambres et le soir
c'est d'abord téléphone et réseaux
sociaux
la génération covit c'est aussi la
génération connu allez bonne nuit